hello everyone i'm back for another
video um after a wildly popular first
video which has now one view after my
first two days of posting it i am
absolutely happy because it means my
friends aren't gonna find this channel
and on me so that's a huge dub for
me additionally as you can see i've got
this haircut and i'm looking hella cute
no but actually um so i initially said
that i was going to do sequel versus
nosql for this video and the more that i
think about it i feel like that's just a
bad idea and the reason for that is that
every single time i go on a youtube
video which is on a systems design
channel and they say let's compare sql
versus nosql the more that i realize
that that's kind of just a complete
oversimplification of the fact that
they're probably now like eight to ten
very different popular variants of
transactions databases now each with
their own benefits and drawbacks and
oftentimes the benefits and drawbacks
are kind of described in terms of like
the type of replication they use the
type of partitioning they use
the type of database engine they use
whether that's you know lstm trees or b
trees as discussed in the last video and
what that makes me think is that you
know screw just going into like let's
choose a database first i kind of have
to introduce all those topics and then
we can kind of go from there
so for for the sake of you know getting
through that first what i'm going to
start with is probably replication and
then
i'll move on to sharding after that but
since replication itself is a pretty
complicated and deep topic i'm going to
start with single leader replication for
today and then i'll go from there so
yeah let's get into that all right let's
talk about single leader replication so
before i go into single leader
replication let's just talk about
replication in general so replication is
when you have a bunch of redundant
copies of a database so that in the
event that one copy fails your
application doesn't completely stop
working and in addition it reduces the
load on each database serving request i
mean this is something i can totally
relate to it makes complete sense you
know i get a lot of load from school i
get a lot of load from i don't know
working out my friends are giving me
their loads constantly so in total if
there were two copies of me it would
work really well for you know spreading
that out
okay types of replication single leader
multi-leader and leaderless in this
video i'll be addressing single leader
so the replication overview for that is
basically this all rights go to one
leader database and the leader can send
a list of rights to other databases via
something called a replication log the
reads can also come from any database
increasing availability so there are
basically three ways to do this and
there are three ways that single leader
replication does this and i'll address
all of them and the procedures you take
so let's say we want to add a new
follower database
it's pretty easy to do in the sense that
we take a consistent snapshot of the
leader database which just means we look
at the leader database at a certain
point in time and copy the contents of
it
and that snapshot is associated with a
point in the replication log and as a
result of that once we copy over that
snapshot to a new node we can go from
that point in the replication log and
start making the changes from there
you can also deal with a follower crash
so at the time of the crash since all of
these nodes are using durable storage
via use of a hard drive we know where in
the replication log that the thing
actually crashed so as a result once it
comes back up you can just fetch the new
changes and start implementing them from
the place where the node crashed
okay finally dealing with a leader crash
this is known as failover and while it
seems relatively simple at first there
are actually some complexities to this
that we'll address after
failover is when you have to determine a
new leader via some source of consensus
so consensus means that all the nodes
have to actually be able to agree on
something let's say one simple way of
doing this is just take the most
up-to-date replica in terms of where it
was at in the replication log and then
step two would be all the clients need
to send rights to the new leader and all
the follower nodes have to actually be
able to pull the replication log from
the new leader
however there are a few problems with
this first of all is that let's say
we have our old leader and it crashes
they're going to be some changes from
the old leader that inherently don't
actually get replicated to the follower
nodes which means that those changes are
just going to get lost and you're kind
of screwed there
additionally sometimes you accidentally
fail over because all of the nodes think
that the leader node is down when in
reality say there may just be a network
congestion and those changes are taking
longer to propagate than you think
in that event you've basically just
created more of a burden on the network
by doing failover and having to
reconfigure all of these things which is
pretty problematic
finally if the old leader comes back we
need to ensure that it doesn't still
think it's the leader this is known as
split brand if it does it might start
accepting rights and then it would lead
to all of our database replicas being
inconsistent which is a big problem
okay let's go into types of single
leader replication so there's
synchronous and asynchronous replication
synchronous replication is when the
client doesn't realize that it has
successfully completed a write until the
right is propagated to all the replicas
uh that is known as strong consistency
asynchronous replication is when the
write first goes to the master database
the client receives that it the right
was successful and then in the
background all of them are propagated to
the replicas
that's also known as eventual
consistency
so the trade-off between those two is
more or less that in strong consistency
the data is always up to date and you're
never going to make still reads however
the rights basically take forever
because they potentially have to go all
the way across the globe and that means
waiting for all of those um i guess all
of that network transport which is bad
eventual consistency on the other hand
leads to much faster writes
but you have to deal with i guess the
perils of having eventually consistent
data which means that you might make
some stale or incorrect reads so i'll go
into some ways that you can deal with
that now
there are probably three main problems
with eventual consistency where
you know even though uh most
applications are eventually consistent
it's probably a fine experience for the
user but these three things stand out as
being cases you probably have to deal
with the first is reading your own
rights so say that um you're on facebook
you're updating your profile because um
you know you're 511 but you want to say
you're six feet
so that people are impressed with you
so you make your change and then right
after you made it you read from a
replica that still says you're 5 11 and
you're angry because you know you want
to look tall
then you also have monotonic reads which
are when reads look like they're going
back in time let's say there are three
rights and then you read from another
replica and that replica only has two of
the rights the first two you read from
another one and that replica only has
one of the rights so it looks like
things are just getting undone even
though they're not
how would you fix that you would
probably just have each user read from
the same replica but i'll go into more
detail on what that actually looks like
finally you have consistent prefix reads
this is when there's a causal
relationship between two writes which
means that the second write really only
makes sense after the first one actually
happens um and then this happens because
those writes are actually on different
partitions so that means that the
database is split up
in a way such that
one write from one partition is going to
be replicated sooner than one right from
the other partition and that's a race
condition and as a result you only see
the effect of the the causal right you
don't actually see the the causal right
itself
so you can maybe solve this by putting
the causally related
events on the same partition or if
that's not possible you may have to keep
track of causal dependencies which means
for this right you know give an id for
the previous right that kind of caused
it
okay so in more depth let's go into
reading your own rights you may write a
change and read from a replica and then
not see it
so what can you do about this well for
editable areas of the application such
as your social media profile you can all
you can have all of those reads coming
from the leader which can be a little
bit inefficient so another way to kind
of change that or reduce the load on
that leader is to only read from the
leader after you know say x seconds from
a right maybe 30 seconds
okay monotonic reads as you can see i
have a very real chat pictured below
which totally happened
so here is me readings from say replica
one but once i read from replica 2 it
starts looking like things are going
back in time the message from 115 is
lost and then if i read from replica 3
the message from 110 is lost
and like i said the way we would kind of
deal with that is by having each user
reading from more or less the the same
replica every single time which you can
do by hashing the user id and then
mapping that to a given replica
okay moving on to consistent prefix
reads
as you can see we have this version of
the chat which is replica one you can
see that causally person a has said
something that has caused person b to
respond
but say those two messages are stored on
different partitions so now replica 2
is going to actually fetch those
messages and person c looking at replica
2 is only going to see that person b
responded but doesn't actually see the
thing causing them to respond so person
c misinterprets the context and then
says something
you know indicating a proper response
how can we fix consistent prefix reads
by the way like i said we can either get
all of those messages for this given
chat on the same partition
or we can say for each messages you know
like give it some sort of timestamp so
we know to
uh like fetch all of the the previous
ones and make sure that we've got all
the causal dependencies
um replication log implementation
options so up until this point i've kind
of treated this replication log as like
a black box where it just says all the
changes but the truth of the matter is
you know you have to actually think
about how this would be implemented as
well because there are trade-offs here
you could copy over the sql statements
used to actually write in the database
but that's pretty bad because some sql
statements are not deterministic which
means that if you were to run them on
each replica you would get different
results and that would lead to
inconsistent replicas
an example of that is just like getting
the current time
you could use the internal write ahead
log which i mentioned in my last video
which basically says like
for this um
you know group of bytes
make this change here but that's also
not ideal because it means that say i
went from my sequel to postgres
the issue there is that
if certain rows are stored at different
parts of disk
those bytes aren't going to make sense
anymore so it actually provides you less
flexibility in the future to potentially
change your database implementation
so finally we could use something called
the logical log which is more or less
kind of i guess what we would think
about if we had to think about a
replication log just you know as humans
which is basically saying um for this
row make this change and it would use
the actual primary key so it's a bit
more verbose in terms of what you're
actually doing but it allows you to be
more future proofed in the sense that
you could probably switch database
engines and not have an issue
you know continuing to do replication
okay so let's talk about single leader
replication and summarize it
the pro is that all rights are going
through one machine which simplifies you
know having to deal with conflicts for
example if i had multiple leaders i
could write two different things about
the same row and then i would have to
somehow resolve that conflict which is
hard to deal with in single leader
replication since all my rights are
going to one place i know that the
database would be resolving conflicts on
its own or there is at least one single
source of truth the con is that since
all rights have to go through one
machine right throughput is inevitably
going to be lower and there are kind of
two ways to deal with that the first is
you could partition the data set so
basically say that
you know for each
you know split each table into parts and
use some sort of hashing function to
split it up but then each partition
would actually have a single leader or
better yet we could use a different type
of replication such as multi-leader or
leaderless replication which in and of
itself has more trade-offs which we will
discuss in subsequent videos
um yeah so all in all i hope this
explains single leader replication
pretty well
like i said i feel like just trying to
do
you know let's choose a database without
understanding all of these concepts is
kind of ridiculous because the
fundamental reasons that certain
databases are better than others for
certain tasks is because they use
different types of replication schemes
different types of partitioning
different types of ways of actually
storing the data or schemas or things
along those lines and i think it's all
pretty important to understand all of
those before we actually you know make
any deterministic statements about we
should use x database for x use case
so all in all again i hope the video is
useful and i'll be seeing you guys in
the next one